supongamos que tenemos una hoja de
cartulina voy a dibujarla por aquí es
una hoja cartulina que mide 20 x 30
centímetros va entonces voy a intentar
hacer que me quede más o menos derechita
creo que es mejor hacer así pequeños
trazos todavía si queda un poquito hecho
acá no no le hace más o menos algo así
vale entonces es una hoja de cartulina
de 20 de 20 x 30 centímetros centímetros
acá y centímetros acá y lo que vamos a
hacer con esta cartulina es una caja
como le vamos a hacer para hacer esta
caja pues vamos a hacer lo siguiente
vamos a cortar en cada esquina así un
cuadradito de lado x entonces en todos
los lados vamos a cortar un cuadradito
de lado x un cuadradito de lado x
también acá también y acá también y una
vez que cortamos esos cuadrados del lado
x todos estos son de lado x pues vamos a
doblar éstas como rectángulos que nos
quedan sin déjame ponerlo aquí líneas
punteadas entonces ya cortamos este
cortamos este cortamos este cortamos
este y entonces vamos a doblar por las
líneas
ahorita un dibujo nada más deja pongo
los las líneas punteadas por acá las
líneas punteadas por acá y las líneas
punteadas por acá entonces como lo vamos
a hacer por ejemplo esta región de acá
déjame marcarla con otro color digamos
con color morado entonces está este
rectángulo de acá lo que voy a hacer es
que lo voy a doblar hacia arriba y este
lo voy a doblar para arriba entonces
como nos va a quedar la caja más o menos
metiéndole un poco de perspectiva más o
menos tendríamos este lado algo así vale
entonces esto lo doblé hacia arriba
de este modo aquí nos queda una una
sección morada va entonces más o menos
va como así entonces este dobleces este
cacho de acá
ahora vámonos a otro vale vámonos a este
de acá que voy a pintar digamos de color
rosa rosa mexicano así brillante para
que se vea igual este lo que vamos a
hacer es doblarlo para arriba como para
allá verdad cuando se dobla queda más o
menos por acá algo de este estilo más o
menos así y más o menos así
alem entonces aquí nos quedaría esta
otra cara que es una cara color rosa
mexicano y de modo similar doblamos este
de acá y este de acá déjame déjame
ponerle más o menos por aquí una línea
rosa entonces por acá viene la caja
y del otro lado de este lado de acá
tenemos una morada
con otra cara morada las estoy pintando
de igual color si son iguales y entonces
como las dos caras moradas opuestas son
iguales pues las estoy pintando igual
entonces tenemos más o menos esta caja
y además nos queda la base entonces la
base digamos voy a pintar la de color
azul entonces estoy acá es la región
azul y esa región azul sería esta base
de acá muy bien entonces ya que tenemos
nuestra nuestra hoja de cartulina y la
doblamos nos queda una caja y lo que
queremos hacer es maximizar la cantidad
de volumen que puede tener esta caja
entonces voy a ponerle aquí queremos
maximizar el volumen volumen entonces
como lo único no volumen tono volumen
ajá como lo único que estamos definiendo
es el valor de x vamos a intentar poner
todo en términos de x y la altura pues
está muy sencilla verdad la altura de
esta caja o de este recipiente es
simplemente x es una caja sin tapa
entonces esta altura es x pero como le
podemos hacer para encontrar el largo y
el ancho o bien el largo y el ancho como
quieras llamarle basta con girar estos
90 grados pues vamos a intentar ponerlo
en términos de x
mira aquí teníamos que media 20 verdad
todo esto media 20 voy a agarrar el
color rosa que es el que utilizan do
parece lado pues todo esto de acá todo
medía 20 pero lo que estamos haciendo
ahorita es quitarle este lado de tamaño
x y este lado de tamaño x de este modo
este lado va a medir 20 menos 2 x si
estamos quitando x de cada lado de modo
similar el lado de acá el largo de la
caja va a medir 30 menos 2 x 30 menos 2
x otra vez mide 30 en total pero estamos
quitándole x aquí y x acá entonces al
doblar la caja este largo este largo nos
queda de longitud 30 menos 2 x muy bien
eso está padre de esta forma el volumen
que queremos determinar lo podemos poner
en término de x como pues para esto hay
que multiplicar el alto por el por el
ancho por el largo entonces nos quedaría
igual a x x 20 - x perdón 20 menos 2 x x
30 - 2x muy bien esto está muy padre ya
tenemos una expresión pero antes vamos a
hacer un poco más cuidadosos y vamos a
preguntarnos dónde puede quedar x vale
porque por ejemplo o sea x no puede ser
negativo si fuera negativo estaríamos
como que agregando cartulina o algo así
entonces en realidad x tiene que ser
mayor o igual que 0 por un lado pero por
otro lado tenemos que cuidar que la x no
se pase demasiado porque no podemos
cortar pues demasiada cartulina qué
quiere decir esto pues que 20 menos 2 x
tiene que ser un número positivo
o sea así si 20 menos 2x fuera negativo
es que nos estamos pasando de la raya y
ya estamos cortando cartulina además
entonces necesitamos voy a poner un poco
más arriba que 20 menos 2x también sea
un número positivo 30 menos 2x también
pero 30 menos 2x le gana a 20 menos 2x
entonces basta pedir que 20 menos 2x sea
mayor o igual que 0 o bien que 20 sea
mayor o igual que 2x y dividiendo entre
12 esta desigualdad nos dice que 10 es
mayor o igual que x entonces ahí tenemos
una gota por arriba para x entonces 0 es
menor o igual que x y x es menor o igual
que 10 muy bien ya tenemos un intervalo
para la equis y lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita es optimizar este volumen pero
no precisamente utilizando cálculos sino
que vamos a hacer una gráfica así en un
plano aquí llega ahorita sacó la
calculadora gráfica dora y ahí vamos a
aproximar por eso es bueno tener el
intervalo de x vale entonces déjame
sacar mi calculadora y 83 plus y
entonces déjame prenderla
y está prendida ok entonces primero me
voy a window mira vamos a ponerle que el
menor valor de x va a ser cero para que
nos quede más bonita nuestra gráfica
luego nos pregunta por el menor valor de
g pues voy a ponerle que 0 porque el
volumen nos va a quedar positivo en este
caso y ahora el valor máximo de gem es
bueno como que saber jugarle a estos
numeritos verdad para que nos quede bien
la gráfica de entrada ya después si no
nos queda podemos variar el tantito pero
cuál sería una buena aproximación para
el valor máximo de y pues saber o sea x
está entre 0 y 10 entonces un valor de
prueba para equipo de hacer 5 vamos a
ver qué pasa con 5 si x en 5 aquí nos
queda 5 aquí nos queda 20 menos 2 veces
5 o sea 2010 nos queda 5 por 10 ahí van
50 50 ahorita me acuerdo de esos 50 y
acá es 30 menos 10 30 - 2 veces 5 es 30
menos 10 que es 20 entonces con el 50 de
acá y ese 20 se hace de 50 por 20 que es
1000 así que más o menos los números
están como que por los miles como me
agarré un número aleatorio
ninguna razón el máximo puede ser que
esté tantito más arriba entonces por si
las dudas le voy a poner que el valor
máximo de i es igual a 1500 entonces
esto de acá es el rango donde voy a
graficar y aquí voy a ponerle la
expresión entonces es x x 20 no 21 no es
x x 20 menos 2 x 2 x x 30 30 menos 2
vamos a ver si lo agarra bien voy a dar
graficar muy bien entonces fíjate ahí
está la gráfica
vamos a jugar tantito con la función
trace lengua picar aquí 3 que lo que
hace es moverse sobre la gráfica y con
esto voy a intentar determinar más o
menos dónde está el máximo entonces aquí
llévale mil 50 mil 53 mil 55 mil 56 mil
56 mil 56 creo que es lo mejor que puedo
obtener entonces yo igual a mil 56 al
parecer es un valor muy alto y ese bueno
es el valor más alto según nuestra
gráfica bueno según la resolución de
nuestra gráfica podríamos aumentarla
pero nos vamos a quedar con este valor
entonces déjame escribirlo es 1000 56.29
ok mil 56.29 lo voy a escribir por acá
ahora sí
entonces tenemos que el volumen máximo
en x es aproximadamente 1000 56.29 vale
y nada más déjame ver para qué valor de
para qué valor de
de x es es para x igual a 3.93 61 que es
para x aproximadamente igual a 3.96 61
que 3.3 puntos 93 a 93 perdón 3.93
61 muy bien entonces eso es lo que nos
dice nuestra gráfica si acá ya se apagó
la cal que es lo que nos dice nuestra
gráfica y bueno le vamos a dejar aquí
hasta este momento en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a ver cómo podemos hacer esto con
herramientas de cálculo para ver si
podemos obtener un mejor resultado
hasta la próxima